The date (as I told you) for sure it was written before the year 95D.C.
But we know from the book itself that the book was written before  the year 70D.C. When the temple was destroyed,
Because the author of Hebrews metions  the tabernacle or temple and priesthood that was still functioning,
For example in Hebrews 8: 4  For if he were on earth,
He should not be a priest, seeing that there are priests that offer gifts according to the law
In Hebrews 8:13 In that he saith, A new covenant, he hath made the first old.
Now that which decayeth and waxeth old is ready to vanish away.
We have an altar from which they have no right to eat those who serve the Tabernacle
Or are still serving in the temple in the Tabernacle,
So it was written before 70 D.C. And the evidence gives us the idea that it was written  before the year 70D.C.
And I personally, I doubt that Paul is the author, but we have we are not sure about it.